Hey,
what's going on is filled bar and it's a Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 9th,
2013.
How you doin?
How are you?
How's your weekend?
How's your Christmas shopping?
Oh my God,
there's throwing people that buy four.
There's not enough time.
What am I going to do?
You know what you're gonna do.
Just bake them a fucking cake.
All right?
You'll walk right up and you mush it right in the fucking cunt.
Happy holidays.
Fuck all you.
You know,
that's the only reason why you like me.
You're going to judge me on my goddamn gifts leg.
Got a gift for you.
It's right there.
You got frosting in your pubes.
All right.
Who else does that for you?
Nobody.
And now you know,
now you know who really cares about you.
I'm sorry.
I'm going to grumpy fucking mood.
I'm having a great time over here still.
It's still in Europe.
Um,
uh,
I'm in the Emerald Aisle,
Ireland.
I'm in Dublin,
Ireland tonight.
Hi Kay.
Tighty Tiki to,
uh,
just landed this morning.
I already called the opening Anthony guys to announced the second annual Patrice
O'Neal comedy benefit.
All of the proceeds goes to his wonderful family.
He's loving family and a,
we're also going to give some money for,
um,
victims of strokes.
It's just a great,
great benefit,
um,
that we're doing again this year because so many people wanted to come last year
we only did one show so people still want to come out and uh,
but also a bunch of other comics were like,
what the fuck bill?
How come you didn't ask me to be on it?
And I was like,
well listen,
you know,
I tried,
I did my God damn best.
All right,
so we're doing it again this year and I'm just going to keep fucking doing it,
uh,
hopefully as long as we can because that's what Patrice was doing when he was
taking care of his family.
So where his friends and we're stepping up and Goddammit,
why don't you just help us step up by buying a fucking ticket?
Well,
we will belt,
but forest,
why don't you tell us about all the wonderful talent it's on the shell.
Well God damn it.
I'm gonna.
All right.
We have the wonderful Jimmy Norton,
Nick Depaulo,
David,
Tell Collin Quinn Dane Cook talent,
myself,
Rich Vos,
Bonnie Mcfarland,
Keith Robinson,
Robert Kelly,
big J.
Awkward [inaudible] Harris.
Stan.
Okay.
You think there's a pet a show out there?
Well then God damn it,
you go to it.
But if you don't come on down Tuesday,
February 18th,
2014 tickets are on sale right now.
We'll have the link if you follow me on Twitter.
Um,
I got that up there already and it's for a wonderful,
wonderful cause and um,
it's becoming this great thing now or we're just going to be celebrating.
Um,
just our great friend and how funny he was in his unbelievable work and it's now
also becoming kind of like a reunion thing.
It's,
it's really become a great thing.
So we'd love you to come down and share the experience with us while raising
money for a wonderful costs.
They you go and,
um,
some of you have bitched to me going like dope.
Why is it on a fucking toes day?
You know,
I got school next day.
I understand that,
I apologize,
but you know,
if you want a great lineup of Comedians,
um,
okay.
You know,
to do what benefit Tuesday is the night when the most guys are in town.
Most people have gigs on Saturday nights and that type of shit.
Um,
so most people are out of town.
So Tuesday night is,
is the night I picked because you know as much as you want to go to this thing,
stand up comics want to be on the show because we all love the guy.
So that's why it's Tuesday night.
I know it's a bit of a pain in the ass,
but hey,
it's a god damn charity.
You're going to bitch about charity.
All the comics are working for free.
Okay,
so go fuck yourself.
One person who complained about that,
that it,
it annoyed me so much that I felt like I needed to address it.
All right,
Sarah,
we are now onto the podcast.
Oh my God.
The place is that banner.
Thank Dave.
Stayed.
I can't remember if I,
if I just did this on opiate Anthony,
but even if I told you about it last week,
I w I need to warn you guys.
I went and I saw the Sistine chapel.
Okay.
And it is the Sistine Chapel.
I thought it was the 16 as in one,
six.
And I was sitting there with the lovely Nia as we were standing in fucking line.
That wasn't even that bad,
that bad,
because it was the winter time.
Uh,
and basically this is the deal when you go in to the,
the Vatican,
I guess the,
the,
the ass end of the Vatican.
Okay.
And I'm going to,
I'm going to really sidestep the easy joke there.
Okay.
With all due respect to all the victims,
when you go into the anus of the Vatican,
you have two options.
When you go into the Sistine Sistine Chapel,
you either go left,
you go right.
Yeah.
Okay.
If you're wired like me,
go to the right,
you'll go right into the Sistine chapel.
All right?
But if you're an unlucky,
dumb cunt,
like myself,
you go,
Ooh,
right.
Left,
right?
Eh,
fuck it.
I'm going left and I went left.
And uh,
you go through the whole Vatican
mmm.
Museum and within there they have every vestment,
every fucking spatula,
every light bulb,
every fucking priest ever used.
And you're walking through it and it just keeps saying Sistine Chapel,
Sistine.
Even though I still thought it was 16 cause I'm a fucking idiot,
right?
So in every other room the ceiling is painted.
So you walk in,
you're like,
is this it?
Is this,
is this,
this,
this date?
No,
no,
keep going,
keep going.
Basically by the time you get through all this shit,
you don't even care anymore.
And then you walk in there and it's ridiculously small.
It's not nearly as big as they make it look on TV,
don't.
And they make it look like it's,
you know,
would like take up the whole ceiling of your living room.
Just that one picture of God sort of a gingerly touching the other guy's finger.
It,
it's just this little fucking thing that you could cut out of the ceiling and
put on your arm,
bring it to all your friends house.
One weekend.
Is that from this,
this 16 chapel Joe?
Yeah,
it is.
So,
uh,
and you know what's worse is once you get in there and then you look in and you
start going,
oh my God,
it's sent that pray with them.
You know what the fuck y'all all the guards who are standing there just sit
there.
Shushing people.
Sure.
The whole time you're in there.
And that's when the standup comic in me slash control free kicks in.
You're like,
right.
You know what?
Fuck you.
Fuck this stupid picture and you silly outfits from 300 fucking years ago.
All right,
you got every God damn thing in this museum IX,
you got every fucking shoe that'd be gold plated.
What are you got everything about the Catholic church in here except for the
rape murder and the fucking pedophilia.
I didn't have the balls to say that because they're their own country.
There are a sovereign state as they say.
So as much as I wanted to say that aside from Bousquet do,
I didn't have the balls to say that or the wherewithal to think of that in that
moment when I was being shushed.
Um,
I didn't know what happens.
Like what happens if you say something like that when you're on the Vatican
grounds?
Do they just kick you back into Italy?
You know what I mean?
Or did they take you down into some dungeon and basically treat you like they
treated a lot of little boys?
I couldn't resist.
Sorry.
Um,
that's great.
No,
a bunch of fucking Jesus freaks are going to know.
If you're a Jesus freak and you're still listening to this,
you're,
you're an asshole.
All right.
What?
You're an asshole.
You know what?
You know what I think.
Anyway,
so let's plow ahead.
So,
so I,
I mentioned I said 16 chapel to Nia.
What did I say too?
I said,
you know what?
This fucking line is so long already.
Forget about in the summertime.
So,
you know,
we should do,
we should open a bar across the street and I go,
we should call it the 17 chapel,
you know,
and she's looking at me like,
what are you talking about?
I'm like,
you know 16 chapel and the cross streets,
17 chapel,
you know,
you,
you get fucked up cause your feed a swung from standing in the line for so
goddamn long.
Did you just sort of cocked her head?
She's like,
Bill,
you've realized it's the Sistine Chapel.
You realize that.
And I just smiled at her and then she just started laughing at me just realizing
what a fucking idiot that she's decided to spend her life.
And I'd love to tell you guys that that was just a joke that that's just a silly
fucking anecdote.
It isn't.
It's 100% fucking true.
I kind of knew it was 16 but it just became 16 in my head.
I have that same disease my dad has where for John Elway's entire career,
he called John on way and you'd be like dad,
Elway,
Elway and be like,
[inaudible] what does it I'm way anyways,
so this just this John on,
wait,
I'm telling you this guy,
he can run,
he can pass dad.
It's Elway.
I heard it just,
no,
let me finish.
Let me finish this guy.
You know.
So I,
I think I inherited that from him.
I,
I don't,
I don't know if I don't hear well,
I'm so wrapped up in my own thoughts as Neil would suggest.
Okay.
But either way,
somewhere along the line,
if it came to 16 chapel,
to me that's his even makes sense to be the 16th.
Every time I think I've hit like the bedrock of my stupidity.
Right.
Some else,
something else comes along.
Um,
anyways,
but since then I have left Italy.
Sadly,
I left Italy.
Uh,
the food was fucking unreal and uh,
you don't kill me.
Oh Shit.
Sorry.
Little bit with this around here.
Oh,
is that,
is that my shirt?
Making all that fucking noise.
I thought that was just in my ear.
God dammit.
How about now?
Is that better now you can move around.
There we go.
I'm literally laying here with a fucking pad of paper under my recorder.
This is so stupid.
I Dunno.
I'm just,
I'm not funny sitting down.
I gotta be laying down or standing up.
All right.
And I'm not walking around for an hour and a half in a fucking
hotel room.
I can't believe all of that had that scratch or anything.
I thought it was in the headphones.
Okay.
Thought there was a bug in there,
like in star trek when they crawled into that guy's fucking year.
Remember they drop those little maggots in there.
It was terrifying.
Um,
anyways,
plumbing ahead.
So I leave at a,
and I fly up to,
uh,
I'm on my way to Glasgow,
so I have to connect in Amsterdam.
And as you fly up,
I saw the entire west coast of Italy who's insane and I just watched that World
War Two documentary and I was thinking of all that stuff,
you know,
the soft underbelly of the Nazi Europe and they came in here and rather than
going into this one part,
they came in the southern part and they had to fight to the fucking mountains.
And that's all I'm thinking.
And you look down and from the air,
so much of it like a,
it's really impressive.
Like even though I'm sure there's a zillion people over there,
like how much of it is still those green fields?
So when you look down it looks like World War Two,
um,
footage.
Except now it's in full color.
Like I half expected us to start dive bombing and strafing some poor bastard
trying to run into the fucking tree line and a,
you fly over the Swiss Alps and then right on up.
And uh,
I was just fucking incredible.
I haven't Goddamn face pressed up against the glass
like some eight year old on his first trip.
I really am a geek for this travel stuff,
man.
It's,
it's,
it's awesome.
So,
um,
landed in Amsterdam,
get all the way up to Glasgow connected,
no fucking problems,
no nothing.
And um,
people,
Scotland that they coolish they cool is how you show up.
The fucking lady checking me and was going to my show that night.
Or there's a guy checking me in,
but the other,
the other lady who was working there,
you know,
most countries should go into,
they're looking at you like you're a fucking terrorist.
You know?
Even though you look like Ron Howard,
they always go,
where are you staying?
I don't fucking know.
What are you going to call me?
And where I was staying in a fucking hotel.
How long are you here?
I'm here for a day.
Oh really?
Well,
he only here for a day for oh cause they're going to blow the whole fucking
place.
That what do you think?
Do you think I'm here for gates?
You see the sad clown in front of you?
What do you think I'm doing here?
Um,
just as pasty as you,
you dumb fuck.
Let me in your country.
Right then.
I liked that.
Then I liked that at all over up in Scotland.
They don't give a fuck.
You're like,
oh that step freckled cut.
I'm going to see tonight at the fucking the shit shack down the straight.
So,
uh,
anyways,
went down,
did the uh,
did the show work with this hilarious guy,
Gary Little opened up for me.
The guy was a fucking riot,
great guy.
And a afterwards I hung out with him and uh,
Kevin Bridges and a bunch of fucking,
you know,
drank whiskey,
Scotch,
whatever the fuck we were drinking and just had a great night talking comedy and
all that type of thing.
So,
uh,
I want to thank everyone who came out to that show.
It was just great,
man.
It was amazing.
Like,
seriously when I was on stage and like Scotland,
I didn't,
I didn't feel like I was outside of the United States except a couple of times I
set a couple of dumb things,
but uh,
you know,
they thought they would get or whatever.
Making fucking baseball references stupid.
Right.
So that one went great.
Next day,
kind of had a little bit of a delayed flight,
flew down to Amsterdam.
That one was awesome at a bunch of people came in from Germany and Belgium
telling me I should do shows there so maybe I'll add those to the next time.
It was just awesome.
And uh,
actually spent an extra day in Amsterdam and I was trying to be mature enough to
not go down.
Sorry,
I gotta move this fucking thing.
I was trying to be mature enough not to go down to the red light district.
You know,
Maria across the street where I was staying from was the Vincent Van Gogh
Museum.
So I'm like,
all right,
I'm going to give museum another chance because I get anxiety when I go into
museums because I go in there and it's all this smart shit in there.
And I could give a fuck after the first exhibit.
Like I literally just want to run through the place and get out of there.
And um,
but I went to the Vincent Van Gogh One and I absolutely it,
I loved that.
And for the first time I think actually appreciated art.
And I,
and I hate to say this,
I think half of the reason was I went by myself.
There was nobody else there,
so I didn't have to,
I'm always like 20 miles ahead of anybody who I go to a museum with.
You know those fucking people you go to a museum with and they actually get the
fucking,
the headphones and the recorder and they just go from exhibit to fucking
exhibit.
They got to watch every God damn film
and I,
I don't,
I should respect people like that,
but I don't,
I hate them.
So anyways,
I went to the Vincent Van Gogh Museum.
It's insane.
They just have his paintings hanging on the fucking wall.
That just sound dumb.
I don't know.
It was always a zillion miles away to me.
Right.
So I'm looking at him and as amazing as they were,
I was still in and out of there in 35 minutes and that includes going to the
gift shop.
I walked in and the first thing I saw was he drew a picture of like,
he was taking this art class and he had to drop like a picture of like the
skeleton or something like that,
a painting,
draw a picture,
paint the fucking human skeleton.
So we painted it and in the end he put his cigarette and his mouth as like a
fuck you to his teachers.
So immediately I liked this guy.
I like this guy.
He's not some goody two shoes,
right?
Even Ganti saying these homework,
he's not that guy,
right?
He's the guy.
He's going to have to fake id and go get you some booze in the fucking late
1880s so I looked at all of his shit and I really liked it.
They go,
that's as deep as I can say.
I didn't really like his chalk period.
Please pay with chalk or whatever.
The black and white shit I wasn't into,
but the thick paint with the lines,
I was into that.
It was great.
The further you step back,
the more it looked like,
what the fuck he was painting.
Then when he got up close look like a bunch of lines.
How do you do that?
You know,
he can't stand 40 yards away with a long paintbrush.
They didn't have that technology back in the 1880s.
They didn't,
don't even tell me they did.
You know,
they look closely at his paint.
He had a bunch of sand and leaves in it.
The guy was out of his mind.
The only thing I don't like is a,
he cut his ear off.
I don't like that part.
You know,
the dumb thing to cut your ear off for.
Although some people would say love is the most important thing in life,
but you know what,
it's not worth,
I dunno.
Turning yourself into Marvin Nash.
She like Mister Blonde and Marvin national at the same time.
Jesus Christ.
It's fucking horrific.
All right,
17 minutes then let's do a,
let's do a little bit of advertising here.
Um,
alright.
Hang on a second.
You know,
I got a decent review on a show I did over here in Europe and someone was trying
to say that I pretend to be stupid and um,
I just started laughing.
I was like,
if that person ever heard me try to read out loud,
they would really retract that statement.
I'm not saying I'm a moron,
but you know,
come on.
16 shovel.
You're going to sign that up.
See fucking spelling,
spelling bee group there.
But whatever man.
Great,
everyone man.
Great.
I'm here to tell you about the man.
It's for men and it's fucking great this holiday season.
Thank the man.
Great.
What is the man great you asked?
They are 100% made in America.
Cast iron grilling grades that are revolutionizing,
revolutionizing the way people grill named one of 2012 best grilling accessories
by men's health magazine.
Mann's great man.
Greats are the perfect gift this holiday season.
Click on the man,
a great banner@billboard.com for the 1999 holiday special.
Remember each Monday morning podcast order comes with a heavy duty grilling
brush.
Again.
That's the man.
Great Grill enhancement system.
Order today at [inaudible] dot com all right.
That was the only one fuck up.
That's not bad.
That's bad.
It's not bad.
One over all right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everyone you know the deal for a couple bucks a month.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing quality.
Razors were right to your damn door.
Not only does it save you a ton of cash,
it saves you from trudging to the drug store for,
for a pack of blades.
Uh,
personally I always get stuck behind them.
You know,
I dunno.
Some hipster trying to buy some mustard gas trimmer.
I don't know what the hell I'm trying to say.
I just got to skip past all this old lady crap.
I don't get stuck behind them.
You get stuck behind some jerk off.
You don't want to be behind and you don't need to be.
Why is that?
Because with dollar shave club for just a couple bucks a month,
amazing quality razor blades and delivered right to your door.
That's right.
No more wasting time and no more getting hit up for 20 bucks.
Every time you go to buy razors.
Everybody here is getting a dollar shave club blades meaning me and you should
too.
And is a genius idea.
Absolute genius.
Try replacing your old shaving cream with doctor caddies.
Easy shave butter from dollar shave club.com trust me,
your face will thank you later.
Uh,
don't waste time at the drug store behind the lady paying in Penny's.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash bar or go to [inaudible] dot com and
click on the dollar shave club banner.
Keep your stress level low and your bank balance high shave time.
Shave money.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash bill burr.
All right,
one more.
A little plus my Hulu.
Plus you probably tried hulu.com.
Now with Hulu plus,
you can watch your favorite shows anytime,
anywhere.
Hulu plus let Hulu plus lets you watch thousands of hit TV shows and a selection
of a claim.
Movies on your television or on the go with your smartphone or tablet and it all
streams in what?
Hd for the best viewing experience possible with Hulu.
Plus.
You can watch your favorite current TV shows like Saturday night live community
and family guide.
You could also,
you could also check out exclusive content including Hulu originals,
like the awesome starting SNLs Seth Meyers and move boys starring Chris O'Dowd
from bridesmaids.
Hulu plus also offers a great selection of a claim films for only 799 a month.
You could stream as many TV shows and movies as you want,
wherever you want.
What more do you need?
I'll tell you what,
right now you can try Hulu plus free for two weeks when you go to Hulu
plus.com/capital B I l.
L that's a special offer for my listeners.
Make sure you use the Hulu plus.com/bell she get the extended free trial and
they know that we sent you once again,
go to Hulu plus.com/bill now or click on the Hulu plus banner on the podcast
page at [inaudible] dot com all right.
That wasn't too bad was it?
Was that sort of painless?
How the fuck did that take?
Three minutes.
Um,
all right.
All right.
Back to the podcast here.
MMM.
What else did I want to talk about?
Oh,
when I was over in England,
I really saw this crazy story.
Um,
but I went to London.
Yeah,
yeah.
MMM.
They had a marine over there,
guy named Alexander Blackman and he just got jailed for life,
for murder of an Afghany and surgeon.
Uh,
it's unreal.
Basically what happened was,
I guess they shot this insurgent guy and this guy,
Alexander Blackman walked up to him.
Let me,
I gotta get the quote here.
What exactly did he say?
Oh,
he just walked up to the insurgent as the guy was laying there,
I guess,
wounded and he shot,
he shot him in the chest and said,
shuffle off this mortal coil.
Sorry.
Shuffle off this mortal coil.
You can't,
it's nothing you wouldn't do to us.
Okay.
And for some reason,
the fucking jerk off behind a mat of camera in his helmet.
And they filmed that.
So now Britain has to act like they don't care that he did that.
Now they have to act like they give a shit and that that's conduct unbecoming of
a good fucking soldier.
Uh,
if anybody can find a four second moment in any war in history where that,
that doesn't happen,
you know,
that's talking about all on the other side.
When they catch these guys,
when they catch y'all guys,
they skin them alive and cut their fucking heads off show as far as I'm
concerned.
That guy got off easy.
Fuck him.
Am I the only guy who saw it as saving private Ryan?
What apple would they let that guy go?
He came right back and started killing that guys just set them over there to
kill the other guys and evidently he didn't do it in the proper fucking way.
Uh,
yeah,
he saved the British people money.
You don't have to feed that guy porridge anymore.
Right?
It's war.
You train these guys to murder people.
He goes out,
he does his fucking job.
He murders this guy and now what?
Now you've got to act like you're outraged because it was filmed.
That guy got fucked over.
He got fucked over the same way the 49 is dead when they played the saints.
Uh,
look,
I am not,
I don't,
I'm not pro war.
I'm not,
but I'm also not a fucking moron.
Okay.
You can't train people to do some shit like that and stick them in those
hellacious fucking environments where that really are no fucking rules
regardless of whatever convention Geneva Convention or whatever bullshit that
you signed.
Give me a fucking break.
All right?
Okay.
I don't think what that guy did was,
I don't even think within the context of war.
Okay.
I mean morally is it right or wrong?
Me Morally wars in right.
I don't understand how I can,
if he's actually was pinned down and he fucking shot that guy in the head,
they give him,
they give him a metal.
I don't know.
That whole thing is fucking stupid.
They,
so the guy has to do at least 10 years and uh,
personally speaking,
I hope they send them to,
I was saying this an opie and Anthony this morning.
I hope they send that guy to the Goodfellows jail,
you know?
Oh,
took,
don't put too many onions in the sauce.
Right.
Okay.
Now we can eat.
All right.
You know,
it'd be great if everybody around the world just quit every army.
That would be perfect.
And then you just let these fucking nerds with their ties right in their beards
and shit.
Just let them have it out.
Right.
There's a fucking hacky thought.
Am I writing the lyrics to a hippie sauce?
Oh,
the loser.
Proud.
Sorry.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
This is fucking tour.
Let's talk is going to be the death of me,
man.
I swear to God.
No,
it is.
I'm want to tough,
tough my way through it because I just read the fucking knew Bobby or book
highly recommended,
highly recommended.
I'm thinking of everything he said in that book,
and it's keeping me going.
I'm just focusing on tonight's game here in Dublin.
I'm not thinking about how I have to fucking connect in a fro.
One more fucking time,
all the way over to Goddamn Helsinki.
I'm not thinking about that shit.
That fucking flight might as well be 20 years in the future.
That's bullshit.
I wish.
I wish I believe in that.
Um,
anyways,
what else?
Well,
I guess I just brought up NFL football.
I did not watch a second of it yesterday.
I'm on the other side of the planet and uh,
I don't know.
When I was doing was trying not to get sick,
I guess I've been eating like shit and uh,
although I did get some,
I got some friendly emails from some Cleveland Brown fans notifying me that the
Patriots won.
Uh,
here's one.
Hey,
you red haired.
Fuck.
Uh,
I haven't you guys exhausted the red haired angle.
This so many other things about me that are stupid looking that you could make
fun of.
You know,
Jesus Christ enough with the fuck.
I get it a day.
A red balls.
I've only fucking times,
you know,
I got a gigantic forehead.
You know,
I'm not going to help you guys out.
You figure it out.
You're one trick ponies.
All right.
Hey,
read.
Yeah,
you read head.
Fuck.
Hope you're proud of the Patriots.
Win nothing like cheating all day to get what you want.
Tom Brady's is sissy piece of shit.
Oh God,
I don't understand how people watch NFL football every week and they don't see
what's going on and they start blaming the other team.
You know,
didn't you see when the Patriots played the fuck in a,
who the hell do we play there?
We end of the gallery of k.
Remember we played that fucking game and the end of the game?
Uh,
they didn't call the interference.
I mean,
how is everybody
fucking league loves to a breed.
He gave me nude fucking these patient adherence cools you fucking full sheet
blue.
It's,
it's,
it's happening to everybody.
All right.
You stupid fuck browns fan.
Did you notice that the NFL settled out of court?
Did you notice that?
That they settled out of fucking court to those,
those fucking,
those hits?
Do you understand that?
They're all about making money.
Okay.
If drew Brees is out,
if Tom Brady is out of Peyton manning is out,
they lose fucking money.
So they are ridiculously protecting all of those quarterbacks.
And like in all sports,
the stars will get even more calls.
All right.
You Dumb Brown cuts.
Okay.
And as far as the pass interference calls,
if you're mad at that,
don't get mad at the Patriots.
Get Get mad at Jim or say and Peyton manning who bitch Moan and complain and
then fucking Rsa spearheaded changing the rules of coverage.
You combine that with the fact that the NFL has hit their saturation point where
there's no more sports fans left to watch the NFL,
so now they have to get people the casual fan of the person who doesn't give a
fuck.
Okay.
If you don't give a fuck about the sports,
that's the sport that you know is on in the background.
The way to get people's heads to turn his scoring,
so everything is about scoring now.
Okay.
That pass interference call when I was growing up was called coverage.
That was great coverage two years ago or a year ago,
maybe two and a half years ago.
That was great coverage.
Now that's considered pass interference.
It's absolutely fucking ridiculous.
It's a travesty I've said every week on this fucking podcast than it used to be.
The thing to do and bay in,
in professional sports in America anyways,
is to hit the curve ball.
Now it is trying to cover a fucking receiver.
All right?
You can't it,
you can't hit him anymore.
You can't touch them.
You can basically run next to them.
But I think you have to hold your breath because you're not even allowed to
breathe on with this fucking point.
And now they got this thing,
you know,
you can no helmet to helmet.
So now they hit low and now guys like Gronkowski just got his knee blown out
because the other guy in Cleveland like two years,
two years ago,
that would have been a dirty hit.
Why did he hit him so low now?
Because of that settled out of suit thing.
You can't,
you know,
helmet the helmet,
uh,
had settled on a court thing.
It came fucking talk.
I'm so jet lagged,
they got to go low then all you fucking constantly internet.
Who's sitting there saying that Gronk Kowalski's made out of glass.
That's just so really,
you could take a defensive back going full speed into the side of your knee.
You can handle that.
You fat fucking cunts.
I'm glad your dreams didn't come true.
How do you like that?
That's right.
I came with no gloves,
no gloves on.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
I can't even speak this fucking week.
What else did I see?
A rose Rosebowl tailgate legend,
that awesome fucking comedian,
uh,
Joe Partner and asked me if I saw the Bruins penguins games.
So I actually watched some of the highlights of that and uh,
you know,
that was very out of the,
uh,
out of character
by,
uh,
Sean Thornton.
I don't obviously don't condone that.
I don't think he does either.
I don't know why he did that.
You know,
I know Marshawn just got hit more Shan,
however the fuck you supposed to say it now.
Uh,
but yeah,
I don't condone that either.
Although I did find it funny.
All the penguins fans,
not Joe,
but the other one's talking about dirty heads,
you know,
as they look the other way with the absolute fucking
okay.
Just some of the filthiest talking people ever have played for the penguins and
they just look the other way.
You know,
Matt Cook,
I'll Sam Samuelson,
all of those guys,
the amount of fucking careers those cuts ended and none of the penguins fans had
any problem with it.
They got old Samson in their ring of honor.
Now I'm going to bitch about Sean Thornton and I'll,
uh,
fuck.
Uh,
but having said that,
I don't condone whether it happens to my team or my team's doing it.
That's,
that's,
that's dirty play,
you know,
and he should be punished.
Uh,
but I mean,
it's the only time I've ever seen him do something like that.
Now if he does it again,
then he's a dirty piece of shit,
which I know he's not.
Gonna.
All right.
Um,
all right,
with that,
what else can I talk about?
What should I do here?
Overseas sports.
I went to a premiere game,
Premier Football League game yesterday.
I went to,
I said,
no,
first average,
and then I guess arsenal was heavily favored and uh,
it was an incredible,
it really was the,
um,
I guess the club itself,
I guess you would call it a,
I don't like naming names on the podcast,
but a,
they hooked me up with tickets through the promoter.
And um,
we sat basically the best seats in the house,
like the club seats,
the leather seats.
They gave me a little blankie for her,
went out there in case I got cold.
I took a picture of it with the Hashtag cozy,
smug cunt.
And uh,
I went out there and it was,
it was great.
Listen to everybody's singing the songs and shit.
But if,
if I lived in England,
I would definitely pick a team and I would go to the pub and learn all the songs
and then I would go sit in the upper deck because who wouldn't want to get shit
faced?
Standing up the whole game singing songs.
It looked great.
So anyways,
it was zero,
zero or nil,
nil.
The exact fucking reason why Americans do not watch soccer or football,
whatever the fuck you want to call it.
And then finally,
but it was still beautiful fucking game to watch.
It really is.
It's a lot like cocky to be honest with you.
Except there it's,
you know,
it's on grass.
Long story,
short arsenal,
finally fucking scores and the whole stadium breaks into this song about
arsenal.
Uh,
I dunno,
they have,
again,
it gets back in the day.
They used to always win one to nothing.
They go,
they score one goal and then like a bunch of cuts.
They just would,
I'll go back on defense and you couldn't score on them as the whole crowd would
sing this song in a one nothing arsenal and you,
you know,
you got to fucking lose and all this shit's so anyways,
so they go up one nothing with like two minutes left and they all start singing
the song,
the whole fucking stadium,
except for this one little corner that was for Everton.
And they get into the second verse,
doll places singing and they got their scarves out.
Hold it up,
going nuts,
big glow in fish and chips,
looks on their faces having a hell of a fucking time.
And when they're in the middle of the second verse average and scored,
Oh did it take the wind out of their fucking sales?
They went to the average that people are going fucking insane.
Somebody lid off like a little smoke bomb that had this blue smoke.
That was the cover of Everton,
I guess you're not supposed to do it.
The cops all came running over and uh,
I dunno,
they just told him to knock it off in America.
They would drag like two rows out,
beaten with clubs.
But uh,
and then all the blue smoke just kind of went all over this one part of the
stadium and that's how it ended one to one.
And I had a great fucking time and a,
I highly suggest it if you are highly recommended,
if you come over to England,
you definitely got to go.
Ah,
you got to go to one of those,
one of those games,
premier league games.
It was fucking tremendous.
And I planned on going into many more and uh,
hopefully in the future.
But,
uh,
this is something that I found that was interesting was,
um,
all the maniacs go does the soccer games and the rich countries go to rugby.
Who would've thought,
right?
The posh cons as they call them,
go to rugby,
I guess in England.
That makes no sense to me.
I would think that rugby would be like,
is it like an elitist sport?
I get that.
I was even talking to the cab driver this morning was I'm going in Ireland.
He was going,
yeah.
A lot of people,
they go on to become doctors and something like that.
Like those guys do.
I don't fucking know.
Is this,
is this even remotely?
Fuck it.
I would say any,
I have no idea.
I've been on a plane every fucking day for the last four days,
so I don't know.
Uh,
what else?
How far into this podcast?
I always a time for the,
how are we going?
Not yet.
Oh,
Jesus Christ Robinson.
Robinson Cano got traded.
He traded,
he signed with the Seattle fucking mariners for more money.
Why would,
why would you do that?
Well,
how would you go for playing second base with the New York Yankees?
He's going to get $190 million.
No,
240 million.
I'm going to go play for the Seattle fucking marriage.
What the fuck are the Seattle mariners thinking,
given up all that God damn money.
Then they learn anything from the Texas Rangers.
Give it a $200 million contract to a fucking shortstop.
You're going to give a tour to $40 million contract or a second baseman.
You know I didn't rub it in with Paul Versey.
I know he's fucking devastated.
He was trying to say,
I'm not mad at him.
You know,
he's got to take the money.
It's a difference of $50 million.
I get it.
Yeah,
I need to get it.
That is a total slap in the face of the New York Yankees.
Okay.
What?
I'm supposed to happen to the Yankees,
you know?
Okay.
I Dunno.
Good on the Yankees to fuck him.
Don't pay him on a fucking $190 million and he leaves.
Go ahead,
leave.
Go out to Seattle.
I have a good time losing Robbie.
Um,
yeah,
I don't think he's going to do shit out there.
Although Seattle's talking a bunch of shit.
You know this,
well,
we're not done yet.
We're going to,
we're going to over pay for even more people.
Um,
she what the Yankees created and then the red sox supported.
Oh,
by the way,
big congratulations to the Seattle Seahawks fans for once again,
screaming mindlessly,
Eddie crowd screaming meter.
Whatever the fuck you doing out there.
Uh,
congratulations on the plaque that was awarded to you that you'll probably have
for like another two weeks before somebody else decides they're gonna.
Yeah,
break the record.
Is any crowd failed yet?
Will they set their minds to screaming for the sake of fucking screaming?
He does have a lot of Seahawks fans think that I'm shitting on their team.
I'm not,
I have money on you Khan to win the Superbowl.
In fact,
if you guys do not win the Superbowl year,
I feel it's a monumental failure because I don't see anybody else in your way
who is in your way.
Nobody.
It's yours to fucking lose.
You got the best God damn defense in the NFL.
Defense wins championships.
You think you can't handle Peyton manning?
Huh?
And that fucking hat box,
head of his,
actually he got to be wearing a top half.
You could put a top hat on his head and it would like,
you could just pull it all the way down.
The Brim would be resting on his shoulders.
So what does that mean?
Bill is not a good quarterback.
Now it does it.
It doesn't mean he's not a good court.
That's a hell of a point in just made.
I am.
Can I really just for one week,
just not shit on Peyton manning.
Um,
anyway,
I think you guys are going to win it,
but that's stupid loudest crowd thing.
I swear to God and I,
and in my heart of hearts,
I know this,
that real Seattle Seahawks fans were there at the game.
They don't participate.
I know they don't.
The same way when I go to a red sox game,
I don't sing sweet Caroline.
I don't buy the pink hats.
I don't buy any of that horseshit.
I don't even wear a red sock shit.
Now when I go to a fucking game,
it's gotten so ridiculous.
So
that's stupid.
Loudest crowd record.
What it should be done is secretly they should be recording crowds.
If you really want to figure out which one is the loudest,
if you're going to throw out the acoustics of the building inside versus outside
versus stadiums,
deliberately designed to be louder.
MMM.
Because if you tell everybody and people were coming down there with those
fucking bull horns,
all right?
They Seattle fence fucking grow up.
Okay.
Keep Your Ryan the price.
They'll blow out your voices.
You got to win the Superbowl this year.
Okay.
Then you can scream and yell there.
What are you going to do?
Try to break your own record and give yourself another fucking plaque.
Oh,
everybody gets a ribbon.
Um,
all right.
That's my little cunty fucking bullshit for this week.
Uh,
what do we got here?
Let's continue on with some,
uh,
some emails for this week.
Fuck.
Am I getting a cold that Jesus Christ,
a little facts for the podcast.
Hello,
Bill.
How are you doing?
Uh,
I was at your show in Amsterdam last week and it was a great show.
Hope you enjoyed your time at hall.
And I did.
I had a great time.
Oh,
I didn't mention,
I tried not to go down to the red light district,
but I had to do it,
you know,
how do you not look at hookers in windows?
It's unreal.
So I went down there by myself,
like a total fucking creep and uh,
I looked at him
and it's a,
it's fascinating and sad and all of,
and I actually saw one guy walking out when I was across the street and shit.
And it's just like,
that guy just fucked a woman,
paid money and fucked her.
It's just the most bizarre thing ever.
But they're a,
they're really good looking,
you know,
as far as like a woman you got,
that was one unbelievable fucking gorgeous woman and she was so good looking.
She wasn't even looking out her window.
She was just sitting at a little desk,
you know,
just like,
look,
you know,
you want to fuck me?
No,
you take your money out and knock on the door.
But I'm not going to stand here at the fucking window.
All right,
let's fucking recording keeps moving around here.
Um,
okay.
And I also saw a skating rink when I was out there and they were playing this
fucking insane music and say was skating around?
Yeah.
Almost like this polka music.
I got to upload the video.
I swear to God.
All of that shit just sounds like Hitler youth music to me.
I don't know why.
Let me see if I can play some of this for you.
I'm trying to find this video.
I sent it to everybody.
I knew it was called it Hitler on ice.
Hope you can hear this.
So this shit's going on is people are skating around.
I just came upon this walking by myself and Amston.
Yeah.
Oh God.
Sorry.
Anyways,
let's get on with this thing.
I said,
where are we?
Anyhow,
I wasn't sure if you're being sarcastic when you stated Holly didn't have
slavery.
I wasn't.
I didn't think you had,
I didn't think you guys had slavery and a bunch of people corrected me.
Oh,
that's right,
because I was in the,
all right,
let me set this up right before I read this email.
Basically I was in Holland on December 5th and that was,
uh,
I guess that Santa Claus is birthday.
Okay.
Not In Holland,
I guess just officially.
That is Santa Claus is birthday.
Santa Claus was a legendary led,
allegedly Jesus bill,
allegedly a real person.
They don't know where he lived at all that.
It's very Jesus like,
but allegedly he's a real fucking guy.
December 5th is when he was born and they celebrate by dressing up like Santa
Claus and essentially putting on blackface.
But it's supposed to represent,
he's gone down every chimney in the city.
So he's got sit all over his face,
you know,
and as Neil was saying,
so would it be sort of strengths rather than put all over their fucking face?
It's black face.
So I was asking them about it and go,
well,
you guys not doing it like an offensive way.
I mean,
you guys didn't have slavery.
Right?
And they had this day at this big laugh.
And I thought that,
oh no,
they,
they all in like,
no,
no.
And I thought they meant like,
no,
we're so against,
don't put that shit on me.
I guess.
Uh,
I guess I was wrong.
So here we go.
Here are the facts.
Uh,
he goes,
since you are like me most of the time,
pretty unformed.
It could be that nobody told you that shifts from Holland transported about half
a million slaves during the transatlantic slave trade in the 17th century.
I check this shit out at Wikipedia,
so it must be valid.
That's hilarious.
He goes,
actually the slave trade was one of the reasons that Holon flourished in the
golden age as we call it.
So yeah,
we did play a role in this,
not really part of our history.
We're proud of,
uh,
you might ask yourself why I wrote a to tell you this.
It's because I'm a con likes to tell people they're wrong.
I don't think you're a con.
I think that's great that you informed me of that.
So,
so they go all righty then.
Okay.
Well,
why would they go up like that?
I guess because they couldn't make it diagonally across some Africa.
Right.
Although if he goes straight across,
she kind of,
okay,
where are you at this point?
Okay.
You went straight across.
She'd be like in Aruba,
maybe north of that.
I don't fucking know cause a mill.
I'll bill,
you know,
do you have to reinforce every three minutes?
How dumb you are on this podcast?
I'll fuck you.
Fuck you with you,
with your brain.
Um,
oh,
this is a reply to that 22 dating 16 year old.
Oh No,
it isn't.
Is it or is it a reply to it?
Anyways,
a few weeks ago somebody wrote in and was saying that my eh,
same way he was 22 or whatever,
I forget,
I'll fucking old.
He was all,
he knows.
His 16 year old sister was dating a 22 year old.
What should he do?
Uh,
so I think somebody is responding to that.
I'm guessing because it says re 22 dating 16.
Uh,
okay.
My Dad started dating my mom when he was 22 and she was 15 gross.
Um,
his dad told him he could get in trouble and advised him to stop.
My Dad told him no,
it is legal as the age of consent is 14 or something here.
Yet,
you know,
when you're fucking somebody that that young,
you probably want to be a little more specific.
No,
it is it,
the legal age is like 14 or something,
40 16,
whatever.
Split the difference.
She's 15 and then you fucking arrested.
He said anyways.
He said,
uh,
they ended agreeing,
they ended up agreeing to go ask a lawyer.
Whoever was wrong,
had to pay.
My grandpa paid the lawyer fees and my parents have now been married for almost
30 years,
but if some 22 year old wanting to date my 15 year old daughter,
I wouldn't have it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
I don't even think that that's a great thing that your parents stayed together
like that.
Did your mom even get to see what was out there before she ended up with your
dad?
Jesus Christ
first restaurant she walks into.
She's just like,
this is the best food ever.
It's never going to get any better than this.
I guess that's good for you.
Right?
So you don't feel like your mom's a whore,
but why would she be a whore?
Why can't she go out and do what guys do?
I'll tell you why,
because,
well,
what would we do?
What it takes skill.
If I mentioned that before,
this podcast,
a guy getting laid,
that's a skill.
All right,
a woman getting laid.
It's just gluttonous behavior.
It's not even this.
Yeah.
Where is the challenge?
There is none.
You can out of the fucking bar right now and have a entire bar on one if you
wanted to.
Right?
What is impressive as a woman,
you know for guy,
if you get a two on one that's like,
you know the fucking brass ring.
What is impressive for a woman?
What are you gonna have like a 15 on one and what is impressive about it that
she could fucking physically take it?
Oh Jesus.
Bill.
That was just,
wow.
That was a whole nother level of ignorance.
All right,
let's,
let's plow.
Let's just plow ahead after that fucker.
One 48 minutes in a,
uh,
Billy [inaudible],
Billy Red Corp Coppola,
Francis Ford Coppola,
Billy Red Coppola.
All right,
I'll go with that.
Uh,
are you going to check out any foreign films while you're overseas?
Dude,
I can't even read advertising.
Do you think I want to fuck a watch a film having to look up and down like I'm
fucking texting while driving.
The earliest thing I want to do that listening to my stuttering voice in my
head.
Uh,
you gotta check it out.
Any foreign films while overseas?
I suggest you do.
It's a trip.
Seeing the cultural differences.
I lived in London and France.
It would check them out from time to time in case you don't make it.
Here's what you're missing.
A test,
a derivative,
Benny Hill style slapstick,
derivative money,
python,
dryness,
derivative theater,
drama,
the occasional deck and more tips.
Some of it's great though,
so maybe you'll get lucky.
I don't know what any of that means.
I guess there's a lot of tits occasionally show somebody deck and they do a lot
of Monty python,
Benny Hill type humor.
Well,
I've already seen the originals.
You know,
why the fuck would I want to go see that?
Thank God I have something better than that,
don't they?
What are those fancy films that comes out at Cannes?
Zed Con Film Festival.
Wrath of Khan.
Uh,
all right,
Bill.
Where's Lenny Bruce?
Bill,
I'm not a standup comic.
I'm not even a huge comic Geek.
I am,
however,
a freedom of speech Geek and comedians are the most important people when it
comes to this.
So why aren't comics who,
for the most part operate independently louder about what's going on?
I just read about a blog by a girl bashing Kurt Metzger.
I don't,
oh,
he's fucking hilarious.
Uh,
he goes,
uh,
I didn't know who he,
but I looked him up and he's really funny.
He makes good points about that stuff.
The blogger just completely labels him a completely labels him things he's not
just because she can understand his context.
You are outspoken about this and I've been honest when asked,
but why aren't people louder?
They were just speaking very vaguely louder about what bloggers bitching about
comedy or bitching about social issues.
He goes,
I don't mean to single out so and so or so and so,
but they're in big positions to speak out against the stifling of the art.
It doesn't anyone want to go down as the guy who stepped up and articulated what
they believe.
It doesn't have to be malicious,
but with some charts and graphs you could explain it to people.
Like that Blogger Jim Norton debated.
I was just going to bring Jim Norton up.
Yeah.
That they're missing the point.
MMM.
Well,
you know,
there is also you,
you kind of hope it just goes away.
If you talk about it,
then they get like more hits.
It's really just like a lazy reporting.
Um,
I saw when Jim debated that blogger or come out show,
uh,
what the hell was it called?
They're a totally biased and uh,
you know,
I thought she was,
for all the ignorance that she was,
yeah.
Talking about like the general terms with which she defined standup comedy and
Comedians and all that.
Like,
especially talking about how angry comics where I thought it was really ironic
that she was sort of the epitome of all of that and she seemed very angry.
She spoke very generally about standup and really had no idea what she was
talking about.
And um,
I thought I said that.
Did I say that on the fucking podcast?
I don't,
I don't give a fuck about,
look,
if somebody wants to go to a comedy club,
I've said this before,
if they want to go to a comedy club and take a comedian seriously,
they are well within their right to do that.
But just because they decide to take a comic seriously does not mean that that
comic now like meant what they said in the joke.
It doesn't make the joke not a joke anymore just because someone decided to take
it seriously.
So,
mmm.
I can only speak for myself.
The only reason why I don't talk about it because I think it's silly
considering all the other shit that's going on.
And then also to sit there and act like,
I can't remember the last time I heard a rape joke.
Like to sit there and act like that's what's going on.
I mean,
I,
I don't,
I don't fuck it.
I that the,
I've already talked about this.
So,
uh,
you know,
where's Lenny Bruce?
That's the navy of thing.
That's a Lenny Bruce moment to fucking say that.
I mean,
I guess what you're saying with the freedom of speech,
but the bloggers have freedom of speech.
They have the freedom to get pissed off about it.
And uh,
I don't know if anything,
they're probably helping comedy.
Maybe a lot of rapists wouldn't come down to the comedy clubs because they
didn't think that there'd be any humor for them.
You're not when,
it's just nice to know that there's enough comics out there that have the
brilliance to understand that rapist before they're caught.
You know,
they like to laugh too.
So there you go.
Everybody makes out alright.
Accidentally dating a high school chick day or bill,
wait a minute.
Accidentally dating a high school chick.
All right,
it can happen.
She's super hot.
You're so psyched.
She's just going to blow you.
You know,
she looks older than her years.
I'm already making excuses for this guy.
Uh,
I'm a 24 year old expatriate Australia that now lives in Europe.
It's every bit the sexual buffet,
that teen titty comedies of the 80s promised.
All right,
this is already getting creepy cause you said accidentally dating a,
a a a highschool chicken.
You just use the word teen.
Okay,
that seems so,
it doesn't seem so accidental.
One sentence in,
please don't be creepy and continuing.
However,
I've recently started dating a certain lady and she's that in every sense of the
words,
smart as a whip.
Caustic is hell and yet warm when you're both alone together.
So here's the backstory.
I've been here a few weeks.
I arrive at this,
at this House party.
I don't even make it past the front hall and I meet this girl.
Everything goes great.
We Hook up and we've been dating for a few weeks.
Fast forward a bit and she breaks off plans,
casually mentioning that she has to study for her.
He writes it in this other language,
the rough equivalent to the American sat sats that don't get me wrong,
the subject of school has come up.
Example,
what subjects was she interested in?
Et Cetera,
et cetera.
However,
this is where the language barrier,
it can be a bit of a bitch.
The Germans and the French can also refer a university as school.
And I naturally assumed she meant university back home.
We graduated 16 to 17 years old.
Oh,
oh gee.
Gee.
So to bring this thing full circle of wondering what,
uh,
I'm wondering,
do I bring it up,
break it off with this chick.
Wait,
dude,
you didn't even say how old she was.
Germans or the French also referred to university.
His school.
Okay.
And I naturally assume she meant university.
That code.
We graduate 16 to 17 years old.
So how old is she?
Yeah.
Uh,
what are you doing dude?
You don't tell me how old she is.
All right,
I'll continue with it.
So to bring things full circle.
I'm wondering,
do I break it off with this chick,
which I think can be a dick move,
given that we've already had enough explorative sex to make HBO look like Dora
the explorer and it's a lever now would look like I've been leading her on slash
using her or do I stay with her and risk our relationship becoming strained by
the different cultural gap?
For example,
uh,
for example,
she's dealing with the high school shit that I've long since resolved myself.
The essentials.
I liked this girl a lot.
We've got a lot in common literature,
arts,
sports,
booze,
and she doesn't find the fact that I collect pre seventies playboys.
Creepy.
Okay.
A huge fucking plus given the woman I've dated.
Oh,
do what the f when did I start attracting like sex offenders.
So you have this weird collection of porn.
You're not telling me how old she is
because she's in high school,
still lives with their parents and his French.
They can be temperamental as fuck dude.
How old are you?
Oh,
he's 24.
What is the age of consent and how old is she?
I don't know what you're saying here,
sir.
How old is she?
I'm not commenting on that.
Do what I need.
I need numbers.
Uh,
right,
right back dude.
Right back.
Let me know how old you are because I don't know what the fuck you're asking me
there.
Um,
anyways,
is that,
oh,
I gotta I gotta do the other half of the fucking goddamn reads here.
That'll maybe I'll tell you a quick little story or something for your bedtime
there.
All he voice,
everyone.
The holidays are coming.
And as a business owner,
you know what this means?
Absolute crickets face it the next couple of months or the calm before the
storm.
Now's the time to do something that will dramatically help your 2014.
What is it?
Easy voice.
He voices his simple technology that helps you to make more money with he voice.
He voices toll free or local numbers.
Call routing tools and a professional dial by name directory.
Your business will look like a million bucks.
And with the voice.
If you could take a call,
they will transcribe the voicemail and they'll email it to you.
You'll never be caught off guard again.
He voice says the saving companies thousands of dollars every month,
making them more efficient,
more productive.
There is no quicker,
easy way to transform your business for 2014 with the voice.
You can try it before you buy it.
Right now you can get a 30 day free trial de Voice.
When you go to [inaudible] dot com slash bill bar or go to [inaudible] dot com
and click on the voice banner,
the voice dot cub built,
that's [inaudible] dot com slash bill barr or billboard.com and click on the
voice banner.
Uh,
okay.
stamps.com and yes,
I realize I just mispronounced my name,
stamps.com with the holidays almost here,
you don't have time to go to the post office traffic parking.
It will be packed with everyone mailing holiday gifts and packages.
So what to do you stamps.com instead with stamps.com you can avoid all the
hassle man of going to the post office during the busy holiday season.
Everything you would do with the post office,
you could do it right from your desk by him.
Print official US postage using your own computer or printer,
print postage for any letter or package,
the incidence,
the instinct,
you need it and then the mailman comes by and picks it up so easy,
so convenient doesn't get any better.
I use stamps.com to send out all my t shirts and my DVDs.
I'm a moron if I can figure it out.
You can't do right now.
Get this special offer when you use my last name,
B U R R for a no risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer that includes a digital
scale and up to $55 free postage.
Come on,
man.
You can't beat this deal.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com right now.
Before you do anything else,
you click on the microphone@thetopofthewholepageoftypeinburrthatstamps.com enter
burr.
And last but not least,
this might be my the favorite name of anything I've ever advertised here.
Uh,
other than one wipe Charlies,
a Sherry's berries,
it says,
insert story when you've given or received,
uh,
the gifts.
Well,
I,
I've been out of town,
I haven't gotten Sherry's berries yet,
are very right.
Sherry's berries since the end of the year is all about delicious holiday food.
Why not send an extra special holiday treat to friends,
family,
business associates,
associates,
everyone you know,
I've never met a person who didn't love Sherry's berries,
sent giant dip strawberries from Sherry's berries for only 1999 that's over a
40% savings.
Go to Barry's dot com click on the microphone and type in Barb Borr.
For my listeners,
double the berries for just $10 more.
Berries are terrific and a sweet holiday gift.
They also have delicious products such as Christmas cake pops,
cheese cakes and dip pretzels is the only way to get this special.
1999 Sherry's berries offer call eight six six fruit.
I'm sorry.
What the fuck am I selling?
Did I approve this?
This is fucking ridiculous.
Who the fuck is going to buy this shit?
This is the 40 shit.
Christmas cake,
cops,
cheese and dip pretzels.
Call eight six six fruit.
Everybody
each song,
sorry.
Eight six six zero dash two or even better method berries.com
oh punch drunk.
Oh,
please spell out the words.
by all means.
Barry's B,
e.
R.
R,
I e.
S.
Barry's.
Click on the microphone on the top right corner and typing.
[inaudible].
You got to see these enormous berries for yourself.
God,
I swear to God.
This is the copy.
Go to paris.com click on the microphone it tipping [inaudible] typing paper.
Dip your balls and dip your berries in that.
Don't wait now order or as some chocolate berries for the fucking person in your
life.
Oh Shit.
I needed that.
That was wonderful.
I'm sure I'll get some complaints on that one.
We need a conference call.
Get do it and I'm in Helsinki.
All right,
wrap it up.
Here we go.
Now that the show is over weight am,
I can't wrap it up.
This quote.
I'll do,
I'll do the wrap up then I'll tell you another story here.
A wrap up.
Here we go.
Now that the show is over,
don't forget to sign up for your free trial of Hulu Plus Hulu plus lets you
binge on thousands of hits,
shows anytime,
anywhere on your TV,
PC,
smartphone or tablet.
Support this podcast and get an extended free trial of Hulu.
Plus when you go to the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com and click on who the
Hulu plus banner or go to Hulu plus.com/bill.
That's Hulu plus.com/bill and you can spend or buy some Sherry's berries because
I'm going to get in trouble for that fucking read and I'm not changing it cause
that was hilarious.
Um,
uh,
wiping tears away here.
Um,
AH,
once I say,
um,
so anyways,
the tour continues tonight.
I'm in Dublin and uh,
I got to show at the Vic theater and then where do I go the whole rest of the
week.
You're just traveling here.
I got Helsinki Tuesday,
Copenhagen on Ah,
AH,
Shit,
Copenhagen Wednesday,
is that right?
Helsinki,
Copenhagen,
then also Thursday and then stock home Friday.
And then I fly to Iceland for the last one.
And uh,
I've been having some unbelievable shows.
I got to tell you something,
man,
that London thing,
you know,
I already know.
I already gave Glasgow and uh,
and um,
Jesus Christ,
Amsterdam fucking punch drunk here,
like,
uh,
um,
but those amazing,
great crowds and everything.
And then London just as far as like just all the American comics that have come
over and gotten their breaks in London,
you know,
from the bill Hicks's to uh,
Patrice O'Neil and um,
I dunno,
that was really definitely a s a special,
that was one of those weekends as I was doing it.
I was,
I was like really nervous before the shows and shit.
Like,
um,
I did not,
I'm not taking any of this trip lightly and this has been an amazing,
just an amazing thing,
man,
to be able to go all through Europe here.
And uh,
I know I'm only here for like a day and that type of stuff.
But,
uh,
this is the beginning of many,
many,
many tours for me over here.
And,
uh,
I'm hopefully going to be saying the same thing about Australia.
I know it got Canada coming up in March and a,
I just want to thank everybody who's been coming out to the shows and I've had a
bunch of standup comics overseas coming up to me and that's like the biggest
compliment you can get.
People,
uh,
comics coming out to shows and coming up and saying that they actually liked
what you do.
So it's really cool.
And uh,
met a bunch of cool fans too.
Um,
they had a couple people where the hell wasn't someone night in London.
Somebody actually got me a cigar,
which is great.
Please don't bring me any more cigars because our,
I'm trying to cut down on that habit,
but I got to thank this dude.
Jimmy came and gave me a cigar.
Uh,
it's just been great meeting the fans and that type of stuff and people getting
the DVDs and shit.
So a,
so really nothing funny.
I just want to,
I'm only halfway through this tap way tonight.
I just want to thank everybody who came out and,
uh,
it's been great.
And,
uh,
that's it.
Hey,
go ended up nicely.
And I,
my apologies to berries.com I didn't,
I didn't look at the copy before I read that this,
I'm too fucking immature to reach shit like that.
I'm sure you have wonderful chocolate covered berries.
All right.
You can go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.